[Música]
eeuu la unión europea y otros aliados de
occidente planean nuevas sanciones
contra las cadenas de suministros rusas
en los sectores económicos que juegan un
papel clave en la guerra en ucrania el
subsecretario del tesoro de eeuu o wally
además afirmó en londres al comienzo de
un viaje europeo para consultar a los
aliados sobre las sanciones contra rusia
que el objetivo era socavar la capacidad
del kremlin para operar su maquinaria de
guerra y es que rusia no produce
internamente una cantidad de las cosas
que necesita para así construir su
equipo militar y por eso entonces quiero
saludar en este momento a nuestro primer
invitado del día el es enrique efe as
técnico comercial economista
investigador principal del real
instituto elcano gracias a enrique
nuevamente por estar con nosotros en
este espacio france24 directo américa la
pregunta entonces cómo afectan estas
sanciones a rusia a la cadena de
suministros en todo el mundo
bueno lo cierto es que lo que se ha
demostrado es que las sanciones
iniciales que se aplicaron contra rusia
han demostrado ser insuficientes al
menos por ejemplo para mantener el rublo
para hacer caer el rublo o para impedir
que rusia siga financiando la guerra
entonces se quiere profundizar un poco
más en las sanciones sobre todo
utilizando sanciones de segunda ronda es
decir evitar los subterfugios o la vía
que tienen los rusos de utilizar
mecanismos alternativos para impedir las
problemas que nos pillan en un momento
en el que ya de por sí teníamos fuertes
restricciones en las cadenas de valor
por los problemas de china y su
aplicación de kobe cero y por los
problemas energéticos y eso lo que va a
hacer es pensar todavía más en los
precios por el lado de la oferta en todo
el mundo claro y también recordamos
enrique que veníamos de una afectación
en la cadena de suministros por cuenta
de la pandemia esto que tanto lo va a
empeorar
bueno la verdad es que no hay ningún
indicador que nos haga pensar que las
cosas están mejorando tenemos por
ejemplo por el lado de china el problema
del cierre de regiones tan grandes como
shenzhen o como como shanghai y eso no
unido al fuerte crecimiento de los
precios del
energéticos y los problemas derivados de
las sanciones a rusia productora de un
montón de materiales muy importantes
para determinadas industrias y la
incapacidad de ucrania para seguir
exportando otros materiales también muy
importantes lo que va a hacer es
multiplicar si cabe la las tendencias
inflacionarias que ya teníamos en los
meses anteriores a no hay ningún
elemento digamos que contribuya a
amortiguar lo que ya veníamos sufriendo
en los pasados meses sino todo más hace
incluso más a acentuar lo claro y además
enrique recordemos que estas sanciones
también por supuesto afectan a los
puertos y todas las vías como del
comercio de rusia también a ucrania
digamos pero por la situación de guerra
el asedio de las tropas rusas a ucrania
ahora yo le quiero preguntar entonces
otras rutas marítimas días de comercio
evidentemente esto aumenta los costos en
todas estas exportaciones importaciones
claro el problema es que no es sólo una
cuestión de
existencia de vías alternativas de rutas
alternativas sino de también de
formas alternativas de carga es decir
nos encontrábamos ya antes de la guerra
de ucrania con con restricciones pues de
buques metaneros de
buques contenedores que nos impedían
a hacer frente a mecanismos alternativos
de transporte es decir ya no solo
cuestionarán de que haya rutas sino
también que existan mecanismos de
canalización o
formas de transportar esos bienes
incluso por rutas alternativas también
enrique a hay una cosa que me gustaría
entender un poco más lo que dijo rusia
de cobrarle el casa que ellos exportan a
los países considerados por el kremlin
como inamistosos en rublos cuáles son
los efectos que va a tener y ya la unión
europea evidentemente rechaza toda esa
esta postura pero o sea qué pasa cuando
estos países entonces deciden pagar en
rublos eso de alguna manera fortalecería
el rublo porque lo hacen
bueno eso fortalecería rublos y el rubro
fuera una importante moneda de divisa
una divisa de reserva internacional pero
no lo es entonces la realidad es lo que
es que lo que aumenta la demanda de
rublos estas si es si es igual que lo
comenta la oferta de rublos es decir
está vinculado únicamente a la compra de
gas no existe ningún incentivo por parte
de los países a mantener rublos que no
sé que no sean para comprar gas lo cual
en teoría el efecto es neutral es decir
es lo mismo en comprar rublos para para
y comprar gas y pagar euros a cambio de
los rublos que directamente cambiar el
gas por euros
de modo que es que estamos hablando de
una decisión más bien desde el punto de
vista político yo creo que se trata
fundamentalmente de un mensaje que
quiere lanzar rusia a evitemos la
necesidad de utilizar divisas de
occidente para canalizar el comercio
internacional es decir es una especie de
resistencia al monopolio de facto que
existe por estas monedas pero que es un
monopolio no necesariamente buscado sino
que se deriva de la altísima demanda que
existe de bienes y servicios europeos y
estadounidenses y de productos
financieros que no existen en el caso en
el caso ruso ahora entre todo esto que
estamos viendo y precisamente hablando
de la energía le quiero preguntar
enrique si el mundo está digamos aportas
de una real crisis energética
ya estamos en medio de una importante
crisis energética y creo que el impacto
va a ser grande en todo el mundo estamos
en una crisis muy similar a la que los
años 70 aunque utilizamos menos energía
que la que utilizábamos entonces pero
eso se va a trasladar en forma de
mayores precios en forma de crisis
alimentaria derivada de los problemas de
suministro determinados alimentos
subidas de tipos de interés que van a
alterar los equilibrios financieros de
determinados países emergentes y por
desgracia me temo que estamos en una
situación muy tensa y si no se soluciona
pronto la crisis no termina pronto la
guerra creo que nos toca vivir momentos
de inestabilidad económica y financiera
en los próximos meses
digamos que mañana siendo optimistas se
soluciona este conflicto una vez ya
igual solucionado cuánto tiempo se
tardaría para que todo este orden
energético digamos se normalice y no
poder estar entonces en esta crisis
energética enrique
es muy difícil de decir hay una parte de
la economía que ya se está ralentizando
como consecuencia de las peores
expectativas y una fuerte caída de las
inversiones pero incluso aunque se
solucione la crisis del punto de vista
militar es muy probable que gran parte
de las sanciones se vayan a mantener sin
probable que haya una solución que
permita eliminarlas las sanciones y
también yo creo que hay alguna serie de
equilibrios que han cambiado para
siempre en relación por ejemplo con
russian relación por ejemplo con china y
creo que vamos hacia un cambio de orden
que que va a tardar en volver a la norma
y decir no creo que volvamos tan
rápidamente a la normalidad que teníamos
antes de la guerra de azúcar y que
además ese orden se traduzca también en
buscar energía limpia y renovable en vez
de seguir buscando el fósiles por por el
bien del planeta también como lo dijo el
secretario general de la onu enrique
gracias por estar con nosotros
nuevamente aquí en directo a mérito del
gran abrazo gracias igualmente